look if we find a star I'm on yes  because that's the point of being on  this show for me like I don't need to  over expose myself well it was a  different kind of overexposure from Katy  Perry that made it on to Monday's  episode of American Idol yes the Idol  judge revealed took too much during one  of the Los Angeles auditions there are  things a man can't unsee he was actually  on a set with the idol team that day and  while there was no mention of Katy's  fall the judges that did let us in on  the filming process so far I'm really  shocked  they did a great job in rounding up the  talent I'm telling you well I thought I  mean honestly I was a little bit  skeptical as to what type of talent was  still going to be discoverable  especially in this information  technology age where everybody's got  their own YouTube we found so many  incredible little nuggets I think that  are ready to polish him it's gonna be a  extremely competitive top ten extremely  competitive